bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors le préfet aurait
donc demandé de procéder à des
arrestations préventives c'est quoi
exactement
ces arrestations préventives dont on
parle alors il n'y a rien de nouveau un
pour être transparents avec vous la
problématique des arrestations
préventives des fouilles préventives
c'est une pour les métiers par an pour
tacler gilet jaune depuis le début
quasiment du mouvement donc qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire
globalement que lorsque vous voulez et
ardres en femelles qui fixe de faire en
sorte de l'étouffer dont comment est ce
qu'on fait on enlève un certain nombre
de personnes mais n'a préventive de la
manifestation soit en amont complètement
de cette manifestation soit carrément
lorsque les rangs commencent à se former
en j'allais dire on tape au hasard et on
prend n'importe qui qui fait à peu près
n'importe quoi d'ailleurs c'est comme ça
qu'on s'est retrouvés avec des gens qui
se sont retrouvés en garde à vue sur les
manifestations parce qu'il était assis
sur le mauvais moment au mauvais moment
soit le monde est bon et qu'on l'a
compris appris qu'il n'avait rien à voir
avec le mouvement des jeunes
donc ça consiste en fait à évidemment
inverser totalement ce qui est le
système français en terme et de garde à
vue de l'arrestation c'est à dire de
partir du principe que quelqu'un va
faire quelque chose alors même que vous
n'avez constaté absolument aucune
infraction mais vous allez parce que la
personne est assise sur un bon
effectivement à quelques mètres du
départ d'une manifestation qui ne va
démarrer qu'une heure ou deux heures
plus tard vous allez partir du principe
que cette personne est susceptible de
participer à cette manifestation de
manière inégale et possiblement de se
prêter un certain nombre d'actes
violents et on m'a projeté tout ça de
façon totalement
inégal pour arrêter un certain nombre de
personnes personnes qu'on va placer en
garde à vue dans un contexte tout aussi
illégal et puis alors à l'époque à
l'époque et pas si longtemps est sûr
donc que ces deux dernières années
maintenant on va légitimer ses gardes à
vue ces arrestations arbitraires d'une
manière tout aussi arbitraire en
utilisant à lensois des comparutions des
crp c'est donc dé plaider coupable en
faisant peur aux gens pour qu'ils
acceptent des peines de des peines qui
sont des petites peines souvent des
stages de citoyenneté ou des choses
comme ça ou alors on va avoir recours à
des compositions pénales ou à des
ordonnances pénales ce que j'avais
d'ailleurs dénoncé de manière
extrêmement fréquentes
lorsqu'on était dans les procès j'ai des
jeunes au quotidien et c'était quelque
chose qui était qui était vraiment
légion voilà donc voila un petit peu ce
que ce sont ceux que son c ces
arrestations préventives ses gardes a dû
préventive
encore une fois bon là on a un document
qui sort dans la presse mais ce sont des
ce sont des choses que moi je vois
depuis des mois
s'agissant d'un gilet jaune s'agissant
de ce ce cadre judiciaire et législatif
puisque finalement au début on faisait
n'importe quoi sans aucun cadre
et puis on a adapté petit à petit le
cadre législatif mais toujours est il
que là vous êtes face à une situation
qui de toute façon être extrêmement
illégales dangereuses qu'on remet en
cause la totalité et de la présomption
d'innocence et de toutes les protections
qui existe dans nos pays pour pas quoi
on n'arrête ont des tiennes
arbitrairement les gens en ski quand
même la base le socle de notre procédure
pénale notamment d'ailleurs préliminaire
ne connais pas sur pénal
outre je vais vous faire un point de
droit mais l'article 6 de la convention
européenne aura le nom de gens passent
donc effectivement on est on est face à
une situation qui complètement
scandaleuse vous avez également
d'ailleurs dans les documents dont vous
faites état il est fait mention des
problématiques relatives aux fouilles
aux fins de trouver des objets qui
peuvent être des ans par destination en
laisant par destination encore c'est une
catastrophe parce que légalement si vous
voulez une arme par destination c'est
une arme qui a été destiné à commettre
des violences et que c'était une des
menaces etc
or pour pouvoir constater la réalité
juridique d'une arme par destination il
faut que cet art et était utilisé par
principe parce que si vous voulez sinon
vous avez un style ou dans votre poche
il potentiellement ce silo est une arme
parce que si vous l'utilisez comme tel
ça devient une arme ce qui veut dire que
dans l'absolu vous pouvez l'utiliser
arrêter n'importe qui qui est autour
d'une manifestation en amont de la
manifestation ou d'ailleurs en aval de
la manifestation à l'événement et le
fouiller sous n'importe quel prétexte
puisque vous pouvez trouver sur lui
n'importe quoi qui va être une arme par
destination
si vous l'interprétez comme tel moi je
me souviens d'avoir défendu de deux
jeunes femmes qui avaient été arrêtés
pour avoir détenu en aval d'une
manifestation gilet jaune des cageots
avec des fruits qui étaient étaient des
fruits pourris les choses non et elle
avait été mise devant en arguant de ce
que les frais en question était
possiblement des armes par destination à
l'encontre des forces de l'ordre sont
vous dire qu'on peut on peut tout dire
on peut tout faire donc team en ont fait
voler en éclats le cadre juridique est
évidemment toute la protection que ce
cadre implique
et aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous dire
sans faire d'humour qui n'en seraient
pas d'accord le gel hydro alcoolique qui
serait une arme par destination parce
qu'on pouvait projeter dans les yeux de
forces de l'anp et et les aveugler sur
le moment où pressage
oui on peut on peut pousser le propos
très très loin et aujourd'hui vous allez
avoir un double problème qui va être
celui de juxtaposer les la législation
gilet jaune combats précédents comme ça
et la législation qu'ovide et lorsque
vous allez effectivement avoir ces deux
ces deux législations sans mesure qui ce
qu'ils se confrontent et qui cohabitent
vous allez arriver à d hérésie totale
je prends un exemple qui est celui que
je pratique beaucoup en ce moment mais
qui je crois est extrêmement parlant
j'ai il ya des mois et il ya encore
d'ailleurs quelques semaines défendent
un nom mail ce n'est pour rien oui très
rapidement parce qu'on a vraiment mis
beaucoup de temps à temps expliqué
simplement ça pour que vous allez voir
c'est à mon avis un extrêmement
pertinent pour comprendre la
contradiction dans laquelle on se trouve
il y a des semaines je défendrai des
gens parce qu'il manifestait avec un
masque sur le visage type ffp2 parce
qu'ils étaient a éclaboussé de gaz et
qu'il voulait se protéger et les mêmes
gens aujourd'hui qu'ils vont manifester
dans la rue seront a priori en
infraction parce que ils n'auront pas se
masquer vous voyez la contradiction dans
laquelle on se trouve aujourd'hui avec
ces législations sur mesure qui
s'accumulent sans aucune cohérence et
avec effectivement des gilet jaune qui
de toute façon ce sont toujours les
coupables quelle que soit le support
qu'on doit utiliser pour cela voilà un
petit peu ce que je retiens m alexandra
des puits merci beaucoup vous êtes
avocate au barreau de la rochelle et
vous défendez des gilet jaune merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous